THERE.
RIGHT THERE, STARING DOWN THOSE
BARRELS.
THAT'S THE KIND OF DEFIANCE
WE'RE SEEING IN SO MANY CITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS, RETIRED
ARMY GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS, THE
COMMANDER OF U.S. CENTRAL
COMMAND, LED THE 101st AIRBORNE
AS WELL IN THE IRAQ INVASION.
IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
MORNING.
AS I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS AND
I'M SURE YOU AS WELL WATCHING
THIS UNFOLD, WE ARE ALL
IMPRESSED BY UKRAINIAN RESOLVE
AND SOME SUCCESSES EARLY ON IN
THE FIRST WEEK OF THIS WAR.
BUT AND I THINK WE'LL PUT THE
MAP UP HERE, RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
ADVANCING, PARTICULARLY IN THE
SOUTH, MORE SLOWLY IN THE EAST
AND THE NORTH, BUT THEY ARE
GETTING INTO POSITION TO
SURROUND KEY CITIES.
WITHOUT SOUNDING PESSIMISTIC,
REALLY JUST WANTING TO BE
REALISTIC, IS UKRAINE LOSING
THIS WAR RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, THEY'RE LOSING SOME
GROUND, JIM, BUT I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE LOSING THE WAR.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A WAR
ULTIMATELY THAT RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN CAN WIN.
THEY CAN TAKE A CITY, PERHAPS,
BUT THEY CANNOT HOLD IT.
AGAIN, URBAN COMBAT, AS I
MENTIONED LAST TIME I WAS WITH
YOU, IS INCREDIBLY SOLDIER
INTENSIVE.
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS.
BEYOND THAT, EVERYONE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY HATES THEM AND
MOST OF THE ADULTS ARE WILLING
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST THEM,
WHETHER IT IS TO TAKE UP
WEAPONS, OR TO BE HUMAN SHIELDS
AS WE HAVE SEEN IN THAT ONE
INSPIRATIONAL SCENE.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
PROVIDING CHURCHILLIAN
LEADERSHIP, PEOPLE ARE UNDAUNTED
AND UKRAINIAN FORCES CONTINUE TO
EXPLOIT THEIR HOME FIELD
ADVANTAGE, SUPPORT OF THE
POPULATION AND THE DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS THEY HAVE MADE
SINCE 2014.
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY GOING TO
SEE IS THE KIND OF CONTINUED
ACTIVITY AROUND KYIV, AROUND
KHARKIV AND SO FORTH, WHERE THE
RUSSIAN FORCES CAN'T EVEN BRING
THEIR COMBAT POWER TO BEAR.
THEY HAVE CREATED A TRAFFIC JAM
NORTH OF KYIV, THEY CAN'T GET
THE FORCES OFF THE ROAD BECAUSE
THE GROUND IS VERY SOFT AND
SOGGY, EVEN TRACK VEHICLES, NOT
JUST WHEELED VEHICLES ARE HAVING
A TOUGH TIME OFF ROAD, AGAIN
THEY CAN'T ACTUALLY GET THEIR
FORCES INTO COMBAT, NOTING THAT,
OF COURSE, A LOT OF THE 40-MILE
CONVOY IS ALSO LOGISTICS
VEHICLES AS WELL.
SO THEY'RE IN A REAL BIND AND
TRAGICALLY I THINK THERE IS
FRUSTRATION, AND JUST THE
WILLINGNESS TO USE WHATEVER IT
TAKES WILL LEAD THEM TO DO MORE
OF WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST
48 HOURS, WHICH IS TO LAUNCH
MISSILES, ROCKETS, ARTILLERY,
CLUSTER BOMBS, EVEN THESE
HORRIFIC THERMOBARIC WEAPONS
THAT SUCK THE OXYGEN OUT OF AN
AREA AND OUT OF LUNGS
INDISCRIMINATELY, GOVERNMENT
FACILITIES, INFRASTRUCTURE, TRY
TO TURN OFF THE LIGHTS, THEY'LL
STARVE THE POPULATION OF KYIV IF
THEY HAVE TO.
BUT THAT POPULATION, I DON'T
THINK, IS GOING TO CRACK.
YOU'LL SEE MILLIONS CERTAINLY
FLYING INTO POLAND AND OTHER
COUNTRIES TO THE WEST.
I THINK THOSE THAT STAY ARE
GOING TO REMAIN UNBROKEN AND
UNDAUNTED.
AND SO THEY CAN TEMPORARILY, IN
A SMALL CITY OR A VILLAGE, BUT
THEY CAN'T HOLD IT, BECAUSE
URBAN COMBAT IN PARTICULAR TAKES
AN AWFUL LOT OF SOLDIERS.
SO THEY'RE IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION, I THINK, AND WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PAST AS YOU KNOW,
JIM, THEY DO NOT HESITATE WHEN
THEY'RE CONFRONTED WITH THIS
KIND OF SITUATION TO DESTROY A
CITY, LIKE ALEPPO IN SYRIA OR IN
CHECHNYA.
AND I FEAR THEY MAY DO THE SAME
THING HERE.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE, FRANKLY IS
THAT THE WORLD IS WATCHING IN A
WAY THAT WAS NOT THE CASE AGAIN
IN SYRIA OR GROZNY, WHERE THEY
CAN CONTROL AND KEEP OUT THE
KIND OF COVERAGE THAT YOU AND
YOUR FRANKLY QUITE HEROIC
COMRADES ARE PROVIDING.
>> THEY CAN'T CONTROL THAT
MESSAGE BECAUSE SO MUCH OF AS
YOU POINT OUT, GENERAL, IS
GETTING OUT, AND YET THEY'RE
DOING EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID.
WE SEE THESE ATTACKS ON CIVILIAN
AREAS.
WE JUST HEARD FROM THIS
INCREDIBLY BRAVE WOMAN WHO JIM
INTERVIEWED, SHE IS VOLUNTEERING
WITH THE MEDICAL SERVICES,
TALKED ABOUT THE ATTACKS ON HER
HOMETOWN, TALKED ABOUT WHAT
SHE'S SEEING, DIRECT ATTACKS ON
CIVILIANS.
SO, YES, THE MEDIA HAS CHANGED.
RUSSIA CAN'T CONTROL THE
NARRATIVE IN THE SAME WAY.
THAT IN NO WAY SEEMS TO BE A
DETERRENT.
>> WELL, AT SOME POINT WHAT YOU
HAVE TO TSTART WATCHING IS WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THE CITIES OF
RUSSIA.
WHEN DO THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
REALLY RISE UP, NOTING OF COURSE
THAT DEMONSTRATORS KNOW THAT
THEY WILL BE TREATED VERY
HARSHLY, PHYSICALLY, AND PERHAPS
DETAINED AND GIVEN A CRIMINAL
RECORD.
BUT AT A CERTAIN POINT, YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE SOME OF THAT, YOU
MAY ALSO SEE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
JUST START TO REFUSE TO CONTINUE
TO ATTACK WHAT REALLY ARE THEIR
ETHNIC AND OFTEN
RUSSIAN-SPEAKING BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
THERE IS A HISTORY OF THIS,
OBVIOUSLY.
RUSSIA EITHER IS EXPANDING OR
COLLAPSING IS THEIR HISTORY.
AND YOU ALSO SAW IN THE
RUSSO-JAPANESE WAR IN 2005 AND
1905 AND ALSO IN 1917, VERY
FAMOUSLY RUSSIAN FORCES
ESSENTIALLY REFUSE TO SUPPORT
THE REGIME AT THE TIME.
THAT'S WHAT BROUGHT ABOUT THE
END OF THE CZARIST REGIME AND
BROUGHT IN THE COMMUNISTS OF
COURSE.
THESE ARE ALL I THINK FACTORS
THAT ARE ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD
WATCH AND TRACK.
THAT COULD BE WHAT WILL FINALLY
PERHAPS LEAD PRESIDENT PUTIN TO
AT LEAST BE WILLING TO CONSIDER
SOME WAY OUT OF THIS, AND THEN I
THINK YOU HAVE TO PERSUADE
SOMEONE LIKE FORMER CHANCELLOR
MERKEL TO COME OUT OF
RETIREMENT, SHE HAD A COUPLE OF
WEEKS OFF NOW, SHE SHOULD BE
RESTED AND READY TO GO, TO
PROVIDE HER WITH SOMETHING
SOMEWHAT REASONABLE.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS
FORCE SOMEONE IN THE STATE OF
MIND THAT WE SEE WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN INTO A CORNER WITH NOTHING